hi everyone this is Jerry this is a game
between Gary Kasparov and Anatoly Karpov
was from the 1985 World Chess
Championship and going into this round
11 game Kasparov was trailing by just
one point in a best of 24 match so
hopefully take something away from this
Kasparov opens the game with one D for
Queen pong game establishing a pond in
the center and allowing the Queen Bishop
to come out Karpov plays Knight to f6
this is regarded as the most flexible
response to d4 the big reason for that
is because this Knight will find itself
on f6 and nearly all variations stemming
from these Queen pond openings so it
makes sense to just kind of get that
move out of the way make that move first
and in doing so you're not yet showing
your hand as to let's say what sort of
pawn structure you're going to set up
what we see next c4 ideally you would
like to play E for but that's out then
I'll just grab it so c4 is a nice
alternative when you do have a pawn in
the center like this you try and get
another pawn up right beside it because
two pawns side by side like this are
usually an asset they control a great
deal of squares and just these two pawns
already at this very early stage in the
game are forming a nice wall controlling
all four of these squares and they're
very flexible either one can move
forward and when they do they're
protected by the other so this is a
strength for for white and it's
important for black to take that into
account and make strides towards
breaking it up so e six heads in that in
a good direction doing two things it
allows the bishop to come out and it
also prepares d5 to try and break these
guys up in the event of d5 if white
captures black can simply recapture with
the pawn and maintain upon on d5 similar
to how white has a pond maintained on d4
so this is the opening phase for the
most part you just try and get the minor
pieces out and in castle so that's why
we're seeing moves like Knight c3 and
Bishop before this move by the way is is
signaling the nimzo-indian defense a
very aggressive move to be playing for
black immediately putting
on the white position pinning the knight
on c3 so already there's new
possibilities in that of knight see
Knight to e4 adding pressure to that
pinned piece typically when you do have
your opponent in a pin it's often a good
strategy to just try and pile up on that
piece that can't move don't don't
capture that pin piece attack that
pinned piece so more development Knight
f3 black castles Bishop g5 one thing to
note ii/3 if you make that move this
Bishop isn't the happiest piece in the
world so that's why we first see Bishop
to g5 so it could at least start to see
some of the black pieces instead of
being shut inside its own little pawn
chain so first Bishop g5 and now c5 well
sure enough you have to break these guys
up you can't just let them sit there
forever so c5 does just that
and the other benefit is that it allows
the Queen to come out along this
diagonal where from that point she will
indirectly put pressure on this Knight
which is still pinned and also
potentially function laterally along
this fifth rank as soon as this pawn
makes a capture she can maybe grab this
Bishop if this Knight gets too crazy so
those are just a couple things to keep
in mind with c5 III multi-purpose move
guards d4 it allows this guy to come out
takes takes and now h6 so there's a
couple issues that black has from such a
position a couple things to really take
into account one thing is that this is
still an asset for white for as long as
they're side by side like this they're
going to prove to be an asset the other
problem the other issue is that this
Bishop is very annoying to the black
pieces the knight is pinned so we got to
do something about that pin it's not a
good idea to just be kept in this pin
for forever so h6 is putting a question
to this bishop what are you going to do
are you going to take my knight if you
do I have the bishop pair in an open
position I'm completely fine with that
so that's not happening and neither is a
move like this where there's no longer a
pin so sure enough what we do see is
just the bishop backing up to h4 and
pretty much saying what was accomplished
by this little h6 move that you did in
fact that is a good question to ask
yourself why is such a move like that
played
let's have
look at some reasons here's one
long-term why's this black King can make
use of h7 as a flight square in the
event that there's a back rank check
later on the skin can make use of h7
what's the downside g6 is a little bit
more weak true that this pun watches
over the square but nevertheless
whenever you make a pawn move in front
of your own king you're weakening your
King side structure in some way now are
you going to be able to as white take
advantage of this in this game no in
other games maybe it did occur where Y
was able to take advantage of it this is
the sort of trade-off that you have to
weigh in your own games but it's just
important to really recognize that for
starters so after the Bishop backs up
another another reason that you could
actually assign for this move is that
from this position on g5 you'll notice
that this Bishop always has the
possibility of maybe coming back to
defend some dark squares that are on the
Queen side however after h6 and Bishop
h4 this Bishop is pretty much just
devoted to the king side and the king
side alone and so unless something crazy
happens this Bishop is not going to be
able to watch over any of these dark
squares pretty it's pretty much devoted
to just being a one directional piece
now
it's just focusing along this one
diagonal whereas for as long as it stays
here it still has you know still
functioning in a couple different
directions so what we do have Bishop
back h4 maintains the pin but now it's a
little less mobile from this h4 Square
so d5 white was able after that exchange
occurred after this c5 and the exchange
occurred white was able to maintain
these two pawns still so you still have
to break them up d5 does just that
putting a question to this little setup
that white has this is an interesting
point right here what we do see next is
rook a to c1 you may be asking yourself
why not you know get my Bishop developed
and get castled that's not necessarily a
bad idea but a move like rook on a to c1
is a very patient move
what's the difference behind moving the
rook and moving the bishop in such a
position let's have a look what we did
see next after rook on a to c1 we saw
the pawns being exchanged and the knight
came to c6 now if you just take a mental
snapshot of this picture from this
position it is of course now White's
turn to play but if we instead make the
move Bishop to d3 opposed to rook to c1
let's see how things are a little bit
different after takes takes knight c6
rook to c1 you'll notice that we have
that identical position however it's now
blacks turn so how did that occur in
short it's it's not magic it's math
right really what it's coming down to is
just a couple just recognizing the
numbers that are involved this bishop in
this position right here how did we
arrive at just this last position well
notice the bishop had to first take a
pit stop on d3 and only then capture on
c4 so I had to take two moves before it
arrived on c4 whereas in the other
variation as was played in the actual
game rook c1 takes takes we have the
bishop going immediately from f1 to c4
which is essentially saving a move and
this translates into a big deal these
are very high level games knowing the
differences between these little moves
like this rook to c1 opposed to just
natural develop development like moves
Bishop to e2 or Bishop to d3 really mean
a world of difference after rook to c1
if this tension is not resolved some
serious problems could be faced by black
for example if Knight to c6 there might
be some tough questions that you could
ask black in this position for example
if a3 is played this is putting a
question to this bishop what are you
going to do if you take my knight I'm
going to recapture and I'm going to be
happy with my bishop pair or in fact I
might even recapture like this to build
my Center and I still have this bishop
pair as an asset so that's likely not
going to happen but what would happen
from here what are you going to do at
your bishop
you go here I'm going to come here if
you go here I might actually press
forward not even give you the
opportunity to take my pond here and
something very serious has just occurred
from this or at this point in the game
something very big has occurred we had a
change in the pond structure what we
have is a three versus two pawn majority
along the Queen side which means that by
force white can go ahead and force a
past pun on the Queen side as black are
you going to be able to cope with such a
thing that's something you have to be
aware of if you're not in a position if
your pieces are not in a position to
cope with that sort of thing you should
really be making this exchange right
away in fact if you try to break it up
we could see something like this and now
we have a connected past pond which is
even more bad news for black in such a
position so these are some things to
really be considering puns upon the pond
structure is really they the ponds act
as a blueprint really for the remainder
of your pieces they act as the
instruction manual for the rest of your
pieces how the pawns are structured
pretty much tells you how you should be
moving about the remainder of your
pieces one out one other alternative is
that the Bishop could maybe just come
here but again keep in mind that this
pond could simply still play here and we
have once again this three versus two
sort of Pama Jordan the Queen side in
favor of white so this does not happen
black does not give white the option to
do such a thing and instead just
captures this right away and we enter
now a structure where which is referred
to as the iqp or isolated Queen pawn
structure white has an isolated pawn on
d4 and it's considered isolated because
it can't be protected by any white pawns
also another thing which is implied by
this isolated Queen pond is that the
square directly in front of it d5 is now
a whole there's no white pond that can
control that square and so what black
will try and do is maneuver about in
such a way so that they could let's say
maintain a piece on that d5 square
because if you're able to maintain a
piece on that square well guess what
this pond isn't going to be able to move
forward that's usually one of the
advance
with having this isolated Queen pond
you're always let's say threatening to
push push forward and maybe mess up the
black position but if black is able to
keep that in control it could really
just turn around and be bad news for
white so what we do see some more
development knight c6 white castle's
Bishop e7 so this is how black is coping
with the pin simply just retreating the
bishop so now this night is finally free
to move notice we're not seeing this
sort of move okay yeah you're out of a
pin but guess what serious weaknesses to
your King side structure these
highlighted squares are now holes
there's their squares that can no longer
be protected by any of the black pawns
so just Bishop e7 let's keep this
structure as is I made one pawn move
nearby King that's enough and now look
to e1 very sensible moves very logical
moves open file half open file the rooks
like those kind b6 allows for the bishop
to come to b7 and develop the bishop can
also come here but that's just it
doesn't really pass the two-word test
which is now what I mean really what is
it what is it going to do next from d7
I've heard people refer to that sort of
a developing move as just being half
developed okay yeah it's off the back
rank you're one step closer to having
these rooks connected one step closer to
having these rooks in direct contact one
another but beyond that what is it
really doing well nothing so b6 is
important it's it's worthwhile to make
that move to spend the time to get this
Bishop on b7 because there isn't a
better diagonal for this Bishop to be on
and you'll notice that from b7 it
indirectly watches over d5 which is the
square that you want to have under your
control in such a pawn structure so next
we have a three what's the purpose
guards before so that there isn't some
Knight maneuver to get to this d5 square
it also allows for the bishop to be
tucked back to a2 in anticipation of
this rook coming to c8 you could
anticipate this sort of move coming
about because that's where the rooks
belong
and open files and half open files and
you know from c8 well that's a that's an
open file so Bishop d7 Bishop g3 this is
just getting out of potential tension as
soon as this night if this night was to
move there'd be tension between the
bishop on h4 and this bishop here so
white is just voluntary white is just
voluntarily getting out of that so next
rook c8 this bishop is unprotected this
Knight is getting ready to move the
bishop would then be hit so let's just
back them up and now Bishop to d6 so
this is a very very quiet looking
position but it's a very critical
position if black if white is not
careful in this position they could
really turn out much worse for example
if I was to just make a nothing type of
move for white let's say b4 doesn't
really do a whole lot at all just weaken
squares on the Queen side this is what
could occur the exchange of bishops
could come about followed by Knight to
e7 and it's really hard to imagine any
more pieces being able to control this
d5 squared that's what you want to do is
black and guess what almost every piece
is doing it in fact I would be
preferring black in such a position
control over that d5 squared that really
is not going to be any sort of attack
that I'm seeing from this point against
the black King so I'd be preferring
black ins in such a position and white
would really be on their heels this
essentially what it's coming down to is
something which would turn out to be a
liability opposed to an asset and so
white is taking this sort of thing into
account and opting to get rid of this
liability so that's why we see d5 at
this point if you don't play it now you
might not ever be able to play without
it without you being able to just lose
that pun so that's why we see d5 right
now and we have a bunch of exchanges
after pawn takes Knight Bishop takes
pawn Trading you know we could see a
Queen trade as well but really this is
just amount amounting to not a whole lot
at all it's just even more simplified
there is
really any imbalance in in this sort of
position prior to this advance right
here we had a structural imbalance but
after these ponds are exchanged really
it's just coming down to all right whose
pieces are better placed so after Queen
f6 Queen a4 if we just do a piece
comparison a piece assessment these are
the things that I'm seeing the Queen's
are roughly equal both are you know
essentially watching over are getting
ready to maybe capture one another's
ponds you know a seven might file after
this guy is captured b2 could fall at
some point of course if we do a night
comparison just get rid of those markers
if we do a night comparison we'll see
that these guys are actually referred to
as counterparts when they're positioned
like this both of them are fighting for
the same center squares d4 and E 5 so
they kind of cancel each other out
there's also these rooks eventually this
rook is going to be placed here in other
words they're functioning on these open
files and so that's ideally where you
want the rook so really there's no
imbalance with regard to the rooks if we
look at the King positions both of them
already have flight squares on the event
of a back rank check we could just bump
our king up if any King is slightly
better or slightly worse off it would be
the black King because if it does have
to make use of this flight square well
you'll notice that there still is a
light square bishop on the board and it
could be subjected to checks however the
white King doesn't face that issue if
it's ever checked it goes to a dark
square there's no dark square bishop for
black on the board so maybe I mean maybe
the the black Queen could at some point
get here and control that square that
might be a downside but I think the more
directing if anything is that if this
black King has to go to h7 that's a
light square and he's kind of just
sticking his head out and getting ready
to be checked by this bishop on d5
beyond that the only other piece to
really focus on I believe this is really
the main feature in the position if
there is an advantage at all in such a
position it lies in the fact that
this bishop on d5 is much better place
than this Bishop on b7 such that this
Bishop is pinning the knight to this
bishop on b7 the knight can't go
anywhere at once you'd have to go to
move a square like a5 so that it's
watching over the bishop but other than
that I really don't see any other
advantage for white in such a position
really just this bishop comparison is
what's telling me that white is slightly
better than black the bishop is
functioning and in X Direction this
bishop really isn't doing a whole lot at
all and right now this pawn is pinned to
the king so that's just one other thing
to note what we do see next is just rook
on F to d8 getting the last piece
involved the bishops attacked rook on C
to D 1 so this is just a pretty much
even position not a whole lot going on
at all next we see rook to d7 I'm not a
hundred percent sure why this move is
played a move like Queen takes pawn here
could have been played I'm not sure why
it wasn't the only thing that I could
come up with is maybe black didn't want
to have this sort of imbalance occur you
know maybe white was anticipating maybe
giving up upon in exchange for now
having a bishop opposed to a knight this
sort of exchange become about the rooks
attacked where does it go exactly it
could code go to c4 but you do have to
do some calculation with that of course
because when you move your books off the
back rank you're susceptible to checks
and if this check came the king could
come here and a move like this isn't
good in this position because it fails
tactically just chop them off and then
hit white with the check we're going to
be hitting we're going to be grabbing
the rook next so there is this was one
approach however black didn't go for it
instead what we did see is just rook d7
looking to just double up double up on
this D file and after Queen to G for the
White Queen from this position is
hitting the rook which is unprotected
and unfortunately for black in this
position this next move was a very
serious blunder the move played which
seems very logical very natural
follow-up to this rook move was rook d8
this was the move play
and it's a serious blunder if you'd like
to you could go ahead and pause the
video and see if you can find White's
reply it's a very very good move of
course it's a winning move and black is
going to end up resigning shortly
thereafter so light to move in this
position pause the video if you'd like
alright the winning move is Queen takes
rook just a queen sacrifice but not
really sacrifice because white is
getting a whole lot more this is just
completely winning there's no other
response but to recapture after rook
check King here what we did see is
Bishop to each four checks the king and
has now discovered attack against the d7
rook at this point Black ends up
resigning what would occur from this
position if play were to continue
g6 rook takes rook and now how exactly
do you cope with the pressure against
your bishop well really you don't if a
move like this is played we're just
going to grab the knight and
unfortunately the Queen is overloaded
she has to watch over the Bishop and
pawn grabbing the bishop will just run
into rook takes pawn and that's mate so
as it went in this game this was the
final position after Bishop to e4 black
ends up resigning and for good reason so
although just prior to this just a few
moves ago was roughly equal um it
definitely shows that even at this very
high level mistakes are indeed still
made so that's all for this video I hope
you got something out of it take care
bye